a lot of decisions you're going to make
in your life but a handful of them are
going to be big decisions in your life
with one of them being having kids and
there's a debate going on right now are
women happier if they have kids or are
women happier not having kids Chelsea
Handler made a video a couple weeks ago
going after Adam because Adam said a
couple different words and she said I am
so much happier for not having kids 45
of working women ages 25 to 45 by 2030
will be non-married no kids single I
sorry but if
the child Alpha content to remind you to
be Alpha you might not be an alpha take
it from an alpha and the truth is
studies show that single women live
longer and are
today we're going to break you down
we're going to give the argument being
made by those that don't have kids on
why they're happier they were going to
make the argument for those who have
kids and why they're happy and we'll
look at a bunch of stats and we'll see
who's right
[Music]
should we give value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so let's get right into a look
Society is going to be selling you on a
lot of different ideas get married don't
get married be poor be rich travel don't
travel go and be with hundreds of men
and hunters and women no save yourself
and only go out there and spend time
with the people you love and date a
couple different before you get married
everyone's selling you their
philosophies God forbid you buy the
wrong one you could lose a decade or two
of your life that's simply what it is so
let's look at some of this data here
argument four not having kids an
argument for having kids here's huffpo
why they're saying it's better to not
have kids you like to sleep you like to
have money you like your freedom you
like to swear you like your personal
space you don't like the appearance or
smell of vomit or poop you don't like
the idea of wiping another person's snot
you like to shut the door while you're
in the bathroom these are some of the
kids they're saying you don't want to
have kids these are some of the things
you don't want to deal with here's a
website called we have kids.com why you
shouldn't have kids kids are messy
you'll be sleep deprived it's mentally
tiring everyone takes longer when a kid
is involved it's hard to travel with
them some good points now let's see the
other side we have kids.com argument for
having kids to carry on the family name
and values to give and receive
unconditional love to give meaning to
life to create and mold a life to have a
family to fix the mistakes of their
parents social pressure and expectations
human biology medium.com said the
following children make us happier avoid
dying alone children give us hope help
us believe in something bigger children
force you to become a better version of
yourself your baby may be the one who
saves the world some of you may be
watching and saying I got 10 more things
I would add to this list yeah I totally
get it I'm just giving you an ID here
but let's look at a couple articles on
what they're saying here's one unmarried
childless women are happiest people of
all says expert if you're a man you
should probably get married if you're a
woman don't bother can you imagine that
if you're a man you should probably get
married if you're a women don't bother
you think someone's going to read that
and say maybe I shouldn't get married
here's another one half of women have
not yet had a child by age 34 the first
time ever figures show women born in
1990 were the first cohort ever where
half were not mothers by their 30th
birthday now if you're part of that camp
you're like oh thank God we're making
progress some of you may say what are we
talking about here what else is the
purpose for not having kids are you
kidding me you don't want to have kids
that's the data telling you watch this
next one here one in four projecting
childlessness among today's young women
meaning one in four is probably going to
have a kid three out of four is probably
not gonna have any kids that's the
direction we're going today but you know
let's look at some other numbers because
when I retweeted Chelsea Handler's video
when she said what she said about men
and Alpha motivation zero I retweeted
and said here's a study from University
of Pennsylvania saying childless women
were 46 percent more likely to be highly
depressed than mothers but then we said
well okay let's play Devil's Advocate
because maybe people are happier that
don't have kids maybe it is something
why don't we look at them break down
four different stats Married with
Children women are married but they're
childless women who are unmarried with
children and those who are unmarried and
childless or they're happier when
they're younger and as they age they get
more depressed and miserable or are they
unhappy when they're younger and when
they age hey I don't have any kids I'm
just happier now let's look what the
stats tells us here's what we're looking
at ages 18 to 34 Married with Children
30 of them were happy but Merry
childless 33 of them were happy which
means those who were married and didn't
have any kids they had more time with
their spouse they were actually happier
than those who were married with kids
then you have unmarried with children 12
percent of them said they were happy and
unmarried childless only seven percent
said they were happy so in this cohort
the happiest ones were who married but
no kids so the argument is go find your
love but don't go have kids it's too
much work now let's see what happens as
you age in life 35 to 54 Married with
Children 28 said they were happy married
childless fell to second place now 24
said they were happy unmarried with
children 11 said they were happy
unmarried childless 12 said they were
happy now comes the next phase 55 enough
because as you're 55 and up you can't be
dating you don't have as many options as
you did when you were in your 20s body
look good everything was perfect maybe
even your 30s you look great you're
going out everybody still flirting with
you life changes a little bit at 55
let's see what the numbers tell us now
you ready
Married with Children 25 happy married
childless massive drop off 14
unmarried but with children 11 and
unmarried childless went to last place
so the happiest went from married with
kids then those who are married without
kids but it's a big drop of from 25 to
14 then unmarried with children and
unmarried childless so when you look at
this data what do you think about the
argument could be made from the other
side to say you see you see even the
person that's very childless is happier
than a person that's unmarried with
child okay so don't have marriage out of
wedlock or something like that okay fine
maybe you can make that argument great
on the other side could be do you see
what happens as you age what used to be
important to in your 20s to go party
hang out go to clubs left and the right
date man date this date that that is not
going to be your priority in your 50s
things that drive you in your 20s are
not going to drive you as much in your
30s than 40s and 50s than 60s life
changes you change I change we all
change my dad's best friend today he's
81 years old it's his granddaughter my
23 month old daughter Brooklyn they're
together glued if you ask my dad what
was his priority 40 years ago it's a
very different thing than 60 years ago
when he was in his 20s right life
changes for all of us we can continue
this here's the study done by National
Library of Medicine data shows that
women with children were significantly
less likely to have depressive symptoms
depressive symptoms
what causes depression what causes
anxiety anxiety is caused by us stressed
out about the future depression is
caused by us stressed out about the past
the decisions that we made maybe one of
the things that causes depression is to
sit there and say man I wish I had a kid
a big mistake on it and you constantly
keep really reliving it that's tough you
ever have to keep thinking about a
decision you made in the past and you
keep recruiting you're dwelling on what
it does to you it's not a good feeling
right now imagine you're 58 years old
you never had kids and all you think
about is I should have kids that's tough
it's got to be painful so how do we get
here could be one of the things like
I've got a bunch of different data I can
show you I don't want to overwhelm you
the fact that hey college degrees it
used to be a lot more men used to get
college degrees for the first time ever
women are getting more four-year college
degrees than men this is a transition
we've looked at from 1940 to 2021 women
are now competing and may be thinking I
no longer need a man I can make the
money I don't need your money I can do
it myself why do I need to have a
husband in the first place and if you
look at right now more women in
Workforce for every hundred in 1990 for
every man working in 1990 74 and a half
percent women today that's 82 which
means women are getting close to having
the same exact number as men and the
argument a lot of times made well women
have babies they can't work as many as
ours as a man does after having kids and
have to take this app to do that fine no
problem I'm just giving you stats on
what's going on and then also income
wise if you look at income wise 65 and
up there's a very big disparity between
how much men make and how much women
make 55 to 64 men still have a big lead
45 to 54 men still have a big leap 35 to
44 men have a big lead but if you look
at 25 to 34 they're making about the
same amount of money and if you look at
20 to 24 it's about the same amount of
money so that that race is getting
closer and closer and closer and if you
look at these stats the U.S national
survey of families and households
determined that those who report being
happy in their marriages declined when
women earned more than their husband
that was set to increase the risk of
Divorce by 50 when a woman makes more
money than a man there's a 50 higher
chance of divorce now you may be able to
stay on the other side and the argument
could be what well that's because men
are insecure and it's it's the insecure
man's fault could be I'm just giving you
the stat don't could be the reason that
this is taking place maybe a man wants
to be the guy that's kind of like
somebody needs me I need it there's a
purpose for me being here you rely on me
and makes me feel important and I want
to do even more for you that could be in
the DNA of a man that naturally we're
wired that way we can go on and on and
on and talk about well you know one of
the things that changes back this before
social media if a girl was a really hot
girl that was living in a state in a
city she would have married somebody
there now she can post her picture on
social media and thousands of other men
could DM her and she could realize look
I'm really hot these guys are dming me
from UK from Spain from Brazil from New
York I don't live in New York I live in
Arkansas I live in you know I live in
this element so that could be one of the
reasons that it changed now all the good
looking men are getting all the women
and the men that would have typically
gotten at least some play today they're
not getting any of it it's hard for men
to find women now a calculator is out
there if you've never used it called the
delusion calculated so with this female
delusion calculator does is it uses
income and marital status information
derived from the 2020 annual social
economic supplement of current
population survey conducted by the
Census Bureau of United States and then
it breaks things down hey I want a guy
that's this tall I want him to be this
way I want him to make this kind of
money what percentage of men who fall
into this category if you've never used
this calculator ladies you ought to use
this calculator to realize the guy
you're looking for how few of them are
in the marketplace but women have way
more options men don't have as many
options so this thing has changed a
little bit but does that mean it makes
women happier long-term stat says no I'm
giving my final thoughts but this
thing's about to take a turn here and
and if you make it to this last part
this is the best part of this entire
message because we have to understand
other people's pain when I interview
people I want to know why you're the way
you are whether you made an incredible
decision and you took a business to
levels that nobody thought you were
going to take it or Kobe or you made a
bad decision and you turn who lets you
down who hurts you what happened to you
I've lived a very weird life this is why
I want to know people's motives on why
they do what they do so Chelsea you know
when she was a kid nine years old her
favorite person in her life she writes
this in the Memoir she wrote which is
titled life will be the death of me and
you too he's nine years old our favorite
person in the world is her brother which
is 22 years old he goes on a hiking trip
and his last words were brothers I will
be back and can't wait to see you he
goes on his hiking trip never comes back
he falls hiking and he dies at 22 years
old she's not she says this guy was my
hero was pretty much her favorite person
in the world Father Figure and her first
boyfriend first boyfriend 9 20 to
imagine the Dynamics of that
relationship
she says look I may be a successful
comedian her words I just felt broken
and didn't know how to deal with these
feelings for years let me read some more
about what happened with her father when
this took place his death had an impact
on our entire family Chelsea notes
emotionally that his death changed the
way she saw relationships because she
felt betrayed by her brother's last word
which were that he would return from the
trip but look what happens here with her
and her father Chelsea's parents are
Seymour a used car salesman and Rita a
homemaker she has spoken at length about
growing up in a household where there
were a lot of unknown variables
admitting my parents were great and
there were a lot of love in our house
but they were kind of hot messes as well
you ready for this next part the
relationship with Dad I didn't like
seeing my father weak I'd already lost
my brother I couldn't lose my dad too
and I did my dad never recovered kind of
changes things right and sinners in
there why would you want to have a kid
can you imagine the fear right let me
have a kid and raise this person nine
years later this person could die in why
would I put myself to that kind of a
pain why get married are you kidding me
that person leaves me why would I want
to go through that kind of look what's a
big challenge men have you you know how
many men fear getting married why do you
think somebody hurt them something
happened mother somebody hurt them they
don't somebody cheated on them but this
is a real issue that a lot of us have
she is not alone here but let me bring
this back to one of the most important
decisions you'll make in your life is
having kids I got four kids our fourth
one Brooklyn 23 months we were not
supposed to have because Jennifer when
she was pregnant with our third Senate
we went out to dinner on her birthday
she's born on Valentine Valentine's Day
my wife and she says look babe I don't
want any gifts from you the only thing I
want is this becomes our last baby
I want 10 kids I want a lot of kids I
love kids and I'm like I don't want to
talk about it right now why are you
doing this I just want this gift I don't
want anything from you I just want you
to look okay great no problem we don't
have any more kids
one day come to the house she says she's
crying in the closet she's like what's
going on baby so babe I don't know why I
want another kid I'm like you want
another kid by the way it's been yours
right I want another you want another
kid yeah what are you talking to another
kid in my mind I checked off that you
know this thing is not something I'm
thinking about I want another kid
anyways we have twins okay
we go to the doctor that whole scene's
like well listen I got some news for you
guys what's that you're not having one
kid you're having two
I'm laughing she's crying that whole
funny mixture motion feeling
12 weeks later one of them doesn't make
it the boy doesn't make it and she makes
it and the doctor says we don't know
which one made it one of the kids is not
healthy so till the day the baby is born
we don't know which one's making it
do you understand what I'm saying to you
we know which one's making us baby's
born it's Brooklyn
is the life of the party she's amazing
I can't imagine my life not having ever
met Brooklyn
do you understand what I'm saying like I
asked the guys here who's your favorite
person in the world one says grandfather
the other one says mom imagine
you're never meeting your favorite
person in the world what's life like if
you don't meet that person right
I can't imagine that now do I sleep more
no is marriage harder having kids yes is
life harder having kids yes is running
companies harder yes it is your health
yes I'm carrying my back you know kids
she likes them yes there's so many
different factors of where you can make
the case for not having kids
but I got to tell you man if the reason
you don't want to have kids is because
of risk of having your heart broken
which is a very valid risk I respect it
if the risk of not wanting to get
married because you're worried about
losing half your wealth because someone
could take it away from you and totally
with I understand marriage is very hard
we take it one year at a time I don't
know how long we're going to be married
it's very hard I never pitch marriage
being easy
but some of the greatest things in life
comes with a freaking big risk a kid is
one of them bro it just is getting
married is one of them it's it's
freaking risky starting a business is
risky moving to a country you don't
speak any language it's risky but
immigrants do it all the time so many
different risks in life so if you're in
the middle and you're actually thinking
about it I'm 44 today I always look at
my hands like this because this hand is
starting to look 44. I look young like
this I look 44 like this right I look 44
here I look 44 here but I love it it's
part of the story you know so I don't
know I'm not going to sit here and
preach to you on what direction to go
with but if there is a decision you
don't want to screw up that's going to
give you so many incredible feelings
make you a better leader help you with
your patience with empathy with
resilience with selfness kids force you
to become better human beings they force
you to become better leaders they kick
your ass in ways that you don't even
know a conversation with your
seven-year-old kid you go to bed you're
thinking about it all night long all
week you're thinking about it at work
they will mess with your head but it's a
good kind of messing with your head and
by the way I'm not selling you you're
saying oh everything's great and we're
going to have great experience with my
four kids I am sure there's going to be
some heart broken on both sides myself
my kids coming I'm not expecting God to
make life easy on me I'm expecting to
make it harder on me but I hope you get
the message from my heart when I hear
something like this I know Chelsea's
going you know she's got the pain not
here trying to be a psychologist she's
got a good life but when you have
somebody that's going through that kind
of pain read why that happened that
doesn't apply to everybody she's lived a
very dramatic hard event life at nine
years old I understand this is a
decision you may want to think closely
about because having kids is one of the
greatest things you'll ever do if you do
it right with the right person that you
think can have a family with hopefully
this got you thinking
[Music]
scared of love it's but you know what
though you you know it's
[Music]
nine years old man you
about
such as I like rock art exterior dude
that's tough man for for I got kids you
know it's not it's not cool to go
through that at night damn
never in a million years did I think I'd
get emotional for Chelsea
but we all got a story you know
all right we gotta wrap this up if you
got value from this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
as a man if you're watching this don't
take this and be like well ladies give
me a second chance and all this other
stuff you got to go and crucial market
value that's what you got to do this
message isn't for you to feel like
you're the victim I'm telling you you go
and prove yourself we made a video
titled the rise of a weak man highly
recommend you watch that video take care
everybody bye-bye
foreign